c'est encore en euros que l'on paie ici
mais donc quelques mois la racine
pourrait prendre le relais
une nouvelle monnaie locale va voir le
jour en valais de ce vol l'objectif est
double d'une part de permettre les
changes
mais en faisant en sorte que cet échange
profite à l'économie locale
mais c'est aussi de créer du lien c'est
aussi de de susciter le dialogue les
changes partage entre les différents une
personne du local les commerçants de
dourdan deal portes du parc naturel
régional se renseignaient pour adopter
la race et qui séduit par ses valeurs
écrit le fondement même le côté le côté
les sites
je dois dire ça m'a un petit peu voilà
sensibiliser le fait de changer ce
fameux mode
j'étais aussi déçu qu'on passe un petit
peu à l'euro j'aime bien le franc est la
racine nos racines puis tout ce que ça
peu dégagé derrière les habitudes de
plantes le marché le soldeur développer
le marché local un travail de
sensibilisation qui devra être mis en
place dans toute la ville pour installer
le dispositif de la racine il serait
peut-être bien organisé une réunion
publique afin de est bien de prendre
l'avis de tous
et puis surtout d'informer parce que
c'est peut-être effectivement
intéressant ce qui va aider les
commerces de centre-ville là pouvoir
rester dynamique et contribuer à l'achat
de proximité et de toute façon une bonne
idée après il faut voir quelles sont les
modalités de dunes
une monnaie locale et comment on peut
être son fonctionnement et 7 monnaies
locales le moi je suis pro contre
l'objectif c'est que tout le monde
participe et tout le monde joue le jeu
aussi bien le consommateur que les
magasins les commerces à une monnaie
fictive qui ne combat pas encore tous
les commerçants mais qui devrait voir le
jour à dourdan en mars 2018